in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Fred
and Lydia are with us hey guys how are
ya better than we deserve love it where
you guys from Cincinnati Ohio oh wow
awesome not too bad a drive what five
hours or so a little less than that yeah
there we go
well good to have you welcome welcome
here to do a debt-free scream how much
have you paid off
we paid off $50,000 awesome and how long
did that take 19 months making what kind
of money during that time we started off
at about 80 85 and then we finished just
north of 100 okay Wow what do you guys
do for a living I'm a pilot for
commercial airline and I am an
appointment awesome very cool very cool
what kind of debt was the 50,000 your
typical we had a her car we had credit
cards and we had student loans so what
happened 19 months ago that made you
guys decide you were gonna do something
different well we got some tidbits or
some good friends of ours who came here
a few years ago and actually did their
debt-free scream and they told us about
the program and everything so we would
always kind of pick their brain and then
ultimately kind of got to the point when
we had gone out which we did many times
going out to eat and buying a couple
drinks here and there and before you
know it you go and hey that car didn't
work let me try this one oh that car
didn't work too like yeah we probably
need to do something about this oh yeah
alright so things kind of get started
getting sneaking up on you yeah alright
enough something's gotta change
yes something's got to go but a lot of
times people don't dive in when that
happens I mean yeah you know then you
guys went home went wide open so you
come home from the card not working and
tell me how what happened then I think
we kind of discussed that we wanted to
do it we kind of dabbled it in you know
we never really jumped fully in yeah it
wasn't until I got my first job working
for a regional airline where we were
like you know what we should probably
take this time to take advantage and
we've been blessed our two mothers are
here with us as well
yes so we moved back home to Cincinnati
to live with my mother and so we've been
able to live rent-free so that was a
huge
and we decided that was the time you
know let's just go ahead and knock this
out
Lydia you moved in with your
mother-in-law I know she's the sweetest
saying that cuz I'm on camera and she's
right here sounded sincere I believed
you you know we've been very blessed
both of our parents helped us so many
times even when we were living out in
Arizona and Fred needed a ride to the
airport because he was based out of
Indianapolis my parents took him at six
four in the morning so like they've been
heavily involved in this process so
we're just grateful that all or another
family member so yeah we've been very
thankful and blessed with that very cool
thank you so you had some good
cheerleaders in the prom
yes yes so now you're those people yep
you're those people that did it
yep you're those like your friends were
yeah you know you're the ones that can't
shut up about it now yeah you hear those
people you and people find out you paid
off $50,000 in just 19 months and they
ask you how did you do that what do you
tell them what do you think um a lot of
sacrifice we had to say a lot of knows
to people more than anything we're
pretty social couples so when there are
strips involved or going out to eat or
just to dinner we had to say no a lot
which was kind of hard but it was worth
the sacrifice and just for our future
and our hopefully our future family it
was well worth 19 months for what we're
gonna live in the future so yeah can't
sacrifice was the secret definitely no
yeah and then I would say cash as well
we stuck to the budget and doing it all
in cash I even got my Nashville envelope
right here free Nashville trip down
below yeah so yeah I was they definitely
doing in cash and we try and tell
everybody we can getting my family my
three younger brothers on it and
everybody else we know they still think
you're a little weird but I'm definitely
well yeah weird you're weird now yeah
like your debt freeze weird nobody does
this yeah so what was the one debt that
when you paid it off you went I hate you
people I'm so glad you're going
the old woman her eviction papers
yep the left foot of fellowship very
very well done okay very cool what was
the biggest budget fight you had
nineteen months go ahead
well it's funny cuz we started this
process and like we said before our
friends were the ones who told us about
the program and I just remember calling
my friend Taylor one time is like I
really need you to pray for us because
we are on week two of the budget and it
has been a struggle there's no big
budget fights in a sense that there was
no one particular thing but sitting down
and every day or not every day every two
weeks kind of running through the
numbers and you know you need this or
you don't and making it work I'm the
nerd she's the free spirit so it was
kind of no no yeah it's really bossy
Lydia not bossy he is a direct very
direct so we just have to work it out
yes good so did you have you had a good
vote though he let you have a vote oh
yeah she gets plenty now we've gotten in
such a good groove for the most part we
can just get together we got our
template and we just boom knock it out
so we got easier if oh yeah definitely
you just got to kind of get through that
first month and then you kind of settle
into a groove and you know what to
adjust and to give and take so well done
okay congratulations thank you got my
start
sharp sharp couple I love it thank you
for coming all the way from Cincinnati
to do this Fred
and Lydia Cincinnati Ohio $50,000 made
off in nineteen months making eighty all
the way up to a hundred count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
that's how it's done right there oh man
fabulous stuff hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show if you didn't know I
actually have my own YouTube channel so
I had to do videos twice a week on life
and money so you can click the subscribe
button to subscribe to my channel and if
you want to check out our video right
now check out the video on how to make a
budget